more legal trouble for Johnson & Johnson
a philadelphia jury has ordered it to
pay 8 billion dollars in punitive
damages in a case unrelated to a string
of big money lawsuits over its signature
baby powder now the jury found the
company failed to warn a man taking the
anti-psychotic drug risperdal of its
side-effects our consumer investigative
reporter andrew warner has been
following the story and joins us at the
table and do you think it paves the way
for other lawsuits like this well that's
a big question right I mean there are
thousands of these lawsuits out there
what does this mean for them 8 billion
dollars is lot it was awarded in the
case of 26 year old Nicholas Marie who
said taking risperdal as a child caused
him to develop breasts an incurable
condition known as gynecomastia
thousands of others have filed lawsuits
alleging the same Murray said he was
prescribed the medicine at age 9 for
symptoms related to autism spectrum
disorder the FDA's approval of the drug
in the 1990s was to treat schizophrenia
and episodes of bipolar mania in adults
now attorneys for Murray alleged the
company marketed the drug for unapproved
off-label use in children to increase
profits choosing quote what they called
billions over children Johnson & Johnson
denies the allegations and says it's
confident that this ruling will be
overturned in a statement the company
says it was quote precluded from
presenting key evidence which it says
showed how the label for the drug
clearly inappropriately outlined the
risks associated with the medicine I
spoke with Murray's attorneys last night
they told me the punitive damages were
meant to deter the company from similar
conduct in the future and they believe
the award will stand but of course eight
billion dollars we've seen a lot of
these big verdicts shut down by judges
later yeah that's a very big one that is
cut it down it's gonna be big gets your
attention there sends a message may not
you know we'll see what happens with it
alright Anna thank you very much